on ne manque pas et l'on demande de
vivre c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
cent mille personnes entre la bastille
et montparnasse les partis de gauche et
d'extrême gauche sont venus parcourir
les derniers kilomètres les syndicats
les organisations humanitaires les
associations de rapatriés les
institutions juives catholique musulmane
sont également représentés
à travers cette marche les organisateurs
veulent dénoncer tous les attentats dont
sont victimes les immigrés mais ils
entendent également mettre en avant un
certain nombre de revendications
c'est ici que la bombe a explosé hier
soir entre 17h30 et 18h 15 qui étaient
visés nous dit il
[Musique]
le monde au racisme c'est une lutte non
violente en découvre à quel point c c on
est plus armé que qu'en étant violent
[Musique]
ce climat de rejet des étrangers qui
s'étend comme un cancer eh bien il faut
la régler
[Musique]
où
et je trouve que j'aurais bien ça aussi
j'avais pas fait ça marche
répond par un mouvement pacifiste à des
actes d'agression et de violence
et justement je trouve que c'est
formidable d'avoir réagi de cette façon
strasbourg le tournant cette fois ça y
est le pari est définitivement gagné
georgina dufoix secrétaire d'état s'est
joint au cortège c'est la reconnaissance
officielle
[Musique]
en partant de marseille s'est passé
qu'on a qu'on commençait un message de
pain à un message e pour l'égalité et
contre le racisme
on voit qu'aujourd'hui par le nombre de
personnes qui est venu il a été entendu
et même par le président mitterrand
[Musique]
oh